question 123 de monsieur antoine lefèvre
transmise à monsieur le ministre chargé
du budget ainsi monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
je souhaitais attiré l'attention de
monsieur le ministre du travail de
l'emploi de la formation professionnelle
et du dialogue social sur les règles
d'assujettissement aux cotisations de
sécurité sociale des indemnités perçues
par les commissaires enquêteurs
collaborateurs aux causes in
occasionnels du service public
l'assujettissement des indemnités que
perçoivent est intéressée aux
cotisations de sécurité sociale pose en
effet difficulté par ailleurs si les
urssaf s'appuie sur le décret 2035 du 17
janvier 2000 portant application
l'article l 311 3 21 du code de sécurité
sociale pour justifier le sujet
tissement des sommes perçues par les
commissaires enquêteurs
il n'est pas sûr que la même lecture
soit faite sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
ainsi lorsque l'état est le maître
d'ouvragé aucune retenue n'est effectué
mais lorsqu'il s'agit d'une collectivité
le montant de l'indemnisation du
commissaire enquêteur est soumis à
prélèvement de charges sociales ce qui
paraît totalement injuste en effet les
départements mitoyens voient leur urssaf
assujettis aux ou non les indemnités aux
charges sociales et patronales
ce qui est source de nombreuses
incohérences enfin en fonction des
procédures d'enquêtés publiques mises en
oeuvre à la prise en charge du paiement
par les collectivités directement ou
dans certaines hypothèses par
l'intermédiaire du fonds national
d'indemnisation des
commissaires-enquêteurs entraîne là
encore de multiples interrogations et
incohérences canton retenues effectuées
de plus la légalité de la désignation
d'un commissaire enquêteur pourrait être
remise en cause
s'il perçoit un salaire de la
collectivité au profit de laquelle il a
conduit une enquête
en effet l'article l 123 6 du code de
l'environnement rappelle l'obligation
d'indépendance du commissaire enquêteur
et donc la nécessité qu aucun lien de
subordination n'existe entre lui et la
collectivité or un salaire peut être
considéré comme un lien de subordination
c'était d'ailleurs l'une des motivations
qui avait conduit à la création du fonds
national d'indemnisation
de plus il convient de souligner que la
décision de payer un salaire un
commissaire enquêteur pourrait également
être remise en cause par l'intéressée du
fait qu'aucun contrat de travail de le
lier à la collectivité considérer aussi
il semblerait plus juste et plus simple
soit de supprimer étant donné les
différentes interprétations faites selon
les juridictions soit à tout le moins de
limiter les retenues aux contributions
csg et crds
en préservant les mécanismes actuels de
calcul qui prévoit notamment des
exonérations totales ou encore une
retenue forfaitaire lorsque lé montant
n'excède pas certain sérieux
en conséquence je vous remercie madame
le ministre de bien vouloir indiquer les
intentions du gouvernement afin de
pallier les inconvénients précités
maintes fois relevées par les intéressés
mais aussi par les collectivités locales
contrainte de verser les sommes
conséquentes au titre de la part
patronale alors même qu'elles sont au
préalable dans l'ignorance du montant de
l'indemnité fixée à posteriori par leur
ordonnance du tribunal administratif
en effet il apparaît temps de trancher
ce litige permanent en adoptant une
interprétation identique pour tous est
connue de tous je vous remercie
merci monsieur le fait madame la
ministre président mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
lefebvre le dispositif des
collaborateurs occasionnels du service
public auquel vous faites allusion à été
institué par la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale de 1999
les commissaires enquêteurs ont été
intégrés dans son champ d'application
par le décret du 17 janvier 2000
modifiée portant rattachement de
certaines activités au régime général
ce dispositif conduite à affiliés au
régime général plusieurs catégories de
personnes qui perçoivent des
rémunérations au titre d'une activité d'
expertise conduite de façon indépendante
à la demande d'une autorité publique
outre les commissaires enquêteurs sont
notamment concernés les membres des
comités de lecture du centre national du
livre les hydrogéologue agréé ou les
médecins des commissions départementales
du permis de conduire dans le cadre de
cette affiliation les rémunérations
versées à ces experts sont assujetties
aux cotisations sociales à des taux
réduits égal au taux applicable aux
salariés du régime général moins 20%
elles sont en outre assujettis à la csg
et à la crds
ces prélèvements sont identiques que les
sommes soient versés par le fonds
national d'indemnisation des
commissaires enquêteurs ou directement
par les collectivités locales
naturellement ces cotisations assure tôt
personne concerné l'acquisition de
droits sociaux notamment en matière
d'assurance retraite
il est important de rappeler que les
règles qui s'appliquent en droit de la
sécurité sociale n'en portent pas de
conséquence en droit du travail de même
qu'elle n'en découle pas nécessairement
plus en particulier l'indépendance de
l'activité d' expertise par rapport à la
personne publique qui la commande n'est
pas remise en cause par l'affiliation au
régime général
pas plus que cette dernière ne requière
l'existence d'un contrat de travail et
la qualification d'une relation de
subordination
la liste des activités qui implique une
affiliation au régime général par
assimilation sans que l'activité relève
obligatoirement du salariat est précisé
dans l'article l 311 3 du code de la
sécurité sociale les causes qui sont
visés à l'alinéa 21 les règles
d'application du dispositif des costes
qui est relativement anciens sont
claires et s'impose sur l'ensemble du
territoire
je vous invite donc monsieur le sénateur
à vous rapprocher du cabinet du ministre
du budget d'alors que vous auriez
observer d interprétation variable selon
les lieux concernés
merci merci madame la ministre monsieur
lefebvre
je remercie madame la ministre pour la
fois ces précisions même si connaissez
bien la réglementation la difficulté
c'est qu'effectivement elle s'applique
pas de la même façon sur tout le
territoire national et je retiens sa
proposition de vous faire remonter
toutes les informations discordantes en
la matière merci à vous